Avant ce personnage, plusieurs fois, les gens de
ma taille n'étaient pas assez compliqués pour que
je sois intéressé à le faire. Je
l'avais fait une ou deux fois auparavant et
vous ne saviez pas que vous m'attrapez, mais ils ont
soulagé mes inquiétudes. Le médecin de Barry
kopits  le gars qui a commencé à
réparer tous les os, ce redressement
des jambes que j'avais fait quand j'avais
environ cinq ans,
j'ai marmonné quand je parlais, je portais une sorte de
cape de femme en velours noir
[Applaudissements] des
collants noirs, des bottes de combat et un air renfrogné
[Musique]
pour une raison quelconque, au milieu de
Brooklyn,
il y avait de la terre dans ma douche, j'avais un rat
mais ce n'était pas grave parce que j'avais un chat désolé,
ça craint après l'obtention du diplôme, c'est vraiment le cas,
je veux dire, je ne sais pas, au moins, c'était le cas pour
moi, mais bientôt  quelque chose commence à se produire
[Musique]
très bien, entrez et vous l'entourez
une fois que vous tenez cette Apple dehors
[Musique] puis-
je vous emmener quelque part non, vous êtes
sûr oui,
je suis indigné par la cruauté envers les animaux chaque fois que
je le vois et comme vous je  je veux faire
quelque chose à ce sujet, je bois et je sais
des choses, j'ai hâte que tu puisses retourner au
travail, tu sais que c'est parfois un de ces boulots,
ou tu sais que je dois retourner
au travail, mais celui-ci, je suis vraiment excité de le
faire.  lis les nouveaux scripts, je serai heureux de
parler des lignées parallèles des
Targaryen et des Lannister plus tard
au bar
[Musique]
tu